Speaker 1: All right. The big political
rally of the weekend was when a soaking,
dripping wet Trump showed up to very windy Texas,
supposedly to campaign in favor of Texas Governor
Greg Abbott and Texas Lieutenant Governor
Dan Patrick and Texas Attorney General Ken
Paxton. It was all about himself. It was all
about me, me, me. I'm the victim. Everything
bad happens to me. And yeah, I guess vote for
these people. Sort of if you need to or if you
want to. A very scary rally. Trump not only
looked disoriented, glitched about a dozen
or 14 times in most rallies. He brain glitches
two or three times, but glitched at at least
a dozen times. But also saying things that are
so crazy that we have to wonder if Trump really
believes this stuff. Something must be going
on where he has entered an alternate reality,
one that doesn't exist here. He suggests he's
going to sue to get people's Pulitzer Prizes taken
away and then wants Fox hosts to be given Pulitzer
Prizes. Fantasy World. He might as well be on Nas.
Speaker 3: So you have reporters from The
Washington Post, The New York Times. They
got Pulitzer Prizes and the Bullets are the
exact wrong thing. So within the next two weeks,
we're suing the Pulitzer organization
to have those prizes taken there.
Speaker 1: That's almost certainly
not going to happen. And of course,
if it does, no prizes are being taken back.
Speaker 3: We'll be doing that over the next
two weeks. I think it's a very good lawsuit, but
we'll see. But when we think of it, they got the
Pulitzer Prize for wrong reporting. But other
people should have gotten the Pulitzer Prize
because frankly, they got it right for years.
And they don't do like prizes for guys like Sean
HANNITY. Oh, but they should buy a different
name. And Tucker Carlson and Jeanine Pirro.
Speaker 1: Imagine giving Jeanine
Pirro a Pulitzer Prize that. But,
you know, most belligerent monologue.
Speaker 3: And Laura and so many different people,
but they don't get anything.
They give policy. So, yeah.
Speaker 1: Really, really scary,
wacky stuff. And then, of course,
Trump pulled out the C-word. No, no, no. Not
about women, guys. Get your mind out of the
gutter. I'm talking about the word communism.
Speaker 3: For our very eyes. Biden and his
left wing handlers are turning America into a
police state. And I don't even think it's Biden,
to be honest with you, but they
got some bad people around.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that at the same
speech, he said, Biden and Democrats don't
care about our police. They're defunding police.
They're getting rid of police and turning America
into a police state. With which police?
Speaker 3: Like something straight out
of a communist country. See, I used to say
socialist, but we skipped socialism. We don't
talk about that. I don't even mention
anymore. We're not socialist and more
communists. We've gone over socialism. We're
gone. It's over. It's communist. They're
talking about communists is a communist system.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, there is absolutely
nothing communistic about Joe Biden whatsoever.
In fact, he's he's almost too much of a centrist
for the Social Democrats to even like him. But
all of these terms are meaningless, essentially,
because Trump and the people behind him don't
even know what they mean. Trump then continues
to tell the lie that it was Nancy Pelosi who
failed to use the military on January six. He's
the commander in chief of the military, though.
Speaker 3: Talk about the fact that Nancy Pelosi
refused to use the military and they didn't
need 10000 to 20000. If they had 500 people,
it would have been more than enough.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, Donald Trump
was the commander in chief of the military at that
time. And remember, Trump claims he ordered 10,000
troops and Nancy Pelosi said, no, there is no
evidence that Nancy Pelosi said no to anybody not,
nor that she has the authority to. And there's
also no evidence that Donald Trump ordered 10,000
troops. You know, like you order a Big Mac. Simply
no evidence of that at all. At another point
during the rally, Trump alluded to a really insane
conspiracy theory that there were satellites that
changed votes from him to Biden. So we've heard
about there were massive dumps. We've heard about,
you know, the number of sandwiches didn't make
sense that they brought for the poll workers.
We've heard all these other conspiracy theories.
But this is a this is an extra crazy one.
Speaker 3: This paper ballots the old fashioned
way. That's the way you're going to stop. Would
you agree with that, Mike? That's the way you're
going to stop it. So the only way we don't need
satellites sending the signals all over the place,
somebody votes. Let's say I'm going to vote for
Trump. I love Trump. I'm going to vote for Trump.
Trump being being because all over the world
comes back by. How did that happen? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Also, it's kind of crazy that
if you see, you know, some of these conspiracy,
you sometimes come across conspiracy theories
that are not based in reality, but they have
an internal logic where like if you accept
that the conspiracy is possible and exists, it
has an internal logic. This one doesn't even
make sense. You're going to insert instead
of just flipping the vote on the machine,
you're going to send the vote through a series
of geostationary satellites, and then it'll come
back as a vote for someone else. Like it's
overtly it's overly complicated. It doesn't
even make any sense. Trump Then this was maybe
the most depraved moment of the entire thing.
Trump said the way to get the information out
of the Russia dossier person is to put him in
court and put him in jail and tell them they'll
be raped in jail. And the crowd laughs at prison.
Speaker 3: Rape easily made public. You know, in
this country, they leak all over the place, even
on the Supreme Court. By the way, you have to find
the leaker of this. You have to find the leaker.
You know how you find the leaker? They'll say,
oh, this is treasonous. What I said. So they
can't find the leaker. He leaked all about Roe
v Wade like this person leaked from the Supreme
Court. Never happened. You know, you find but
they don't want to mention this because I think
it's so terrible. You take the writer because
you're never going to find it out. They're going
through phone records. It's been a long time. You
take the writer and or the publisher of the paper,
a certain paper, and, you know, and you
say, who is the leaker? National security?
And they say, we're not going to tell you
this. It's okay. You're going to jail.
And when this person realizes that he is going
to be the bride of another prisoner very shortly,
he will say, I'd very much like to tell
you exactly who that leaker it was built.
Speaker 1: So the joke is, our prisons
are so unsafe sometimes. These people
are sexually assaulted. Oh that Donald Trump
is so clever. Dystopian moment the a group
of Q and on type people interrupted Trump and
started singing the national anthem at the rally
and Trump allowed the entire thing to go on.
Speaker 3: Damn it all surprise dorks. These
are the people we have to remember
this January six, this committee.
The two things they didn't talk about, two things
was that the people went down there and you could
have had over a million people and they.
Speaker 1:
Cult. So understand. And they sing the entire
thing. Understand what happened there. Okay. Cult
leader Trump was bemoaning that they are going
after the January 6th rioters. And as he does
that, in a show of defiance and seemingly support
for the rioters, and I guess they're implying the
rioters did something very patriotic. The crowd
stands up led by a sort of conspiracy group in
the front row area. Based on reports I've read.
And starts singing the national anthem. This is
a cult. Anything the cult leader says must be
defended. And if it says if he says something
really crazy, you get up and you sing the national
anthem. Trump then ranting about the boxes,
continuing to make wild claims, this time about
presidents putting boxes in Chinese laundries. And
I can assure you this does nothing to exculpate
Trump from what he did with those documents.
Speaker 3: And look at me for a long time, Dr.
Arnie. I'll tell you what they found nothing. They
have found one thing I will say. They found that
I, like you, emigrate, Patria. That's what they.
It's a disgrace. What's going on? Like
the boxes hoax. Have you looked at the
boxes? Hoax. Okay. This is the new one. The
boxes. You know, Mar-A-Lago. Have you seen the
last five or six presidents? What they did,
they took it. They're in Chinese laundries.
They're stored there in storage houses where the
windows and doors are broken. It's a disgrace.
Speaker 1: But now we've already looked at each
of those claims individually. They're all either
deceptive or outright false, but it doesn't
matter. They just grow while the Cunanan music
played. Then Trump attacked electric vehicles.
Speaker 3: We are a nation whose leaders are
demanding all electric cars, even demanding
though they can't go far and cost too much.
And whose batteries are produced in China
with materials only available in China
when an unlimited amount of gasoline is
available inexpensively in the United States
but not available in China?
Speaker 1: Yeah,
there are now. This is conservatively two electric
vehicles with a 400 plus mile range. There are
15 electric vehicles with a 300 plus mile
range and there are almost 20 with a 250
mile range. So it's it's just pathetic. Now,
maybe the cult, this moment of the rally,
Trump calls up Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton
to speak. When you go up there, if the cult leader
gives you an opportunity to speak, you should
damn well better know that you're supposed to
just praise the cult leader when you're allowed
to speak. And that's exactly what Ken Paxton does.
Speaker 3: Hey, so. So, Mr. President,
Dan Patrick and I were over here asking,
how does this president draw a crowd year
after year, thousands of people unlike
anybody we've ever seen. And and so I've been
sitting here trying to figure it out. Right.
And and the question I thought was, what did.
Speaker 1: You determine, Ken?
Speaker 3: Maybe he's a great speaker.
Well, Mr. President, that's true. You're
a great speaker. But I don't think that's why
everybody's here. Is it because he's a great
businessman now? Clearly is a great businessmen,
but I don't think that's why everybody's here.
Maybe it's because you're a great golfer.
I don't think that's why everybody's here.
This president and the people that come to see
him are here because in my opinion, you tell
me I'm right. He's done more for the American
people than any president in our lifetime. Hey.
Speaker 1: So he was certainly on message. He
knew exactly what he was supposed to do. Scary
cult rally. These are serious cultists. Serious
interventions would be necessary to get them out.
And if you need more proof of that, let's look
at some of the interviews with the cult members